[Música]
viajar nunca fez parte da minha rotina e
para ser sincera eu nunca pensei que
fosse fazer um dia mas alguns anos atrás
em um universo paralelo
eu era uma funcionária de tiê numa
empresa de telecom
eu tinha um hobby nessa época eu gostava
de fotografia
só que a fotografia foi tomando um
espaço cada vez maior na minha vida é
uma atividade que ia cada vez mais me
dando muito prazer ao ponto de eu chegar
pro meu marido e perguntar o que você
acha de investir nessa carreira de
fotografia de casamento profissional
casamento porque eu já sabia que gostava
de balada e aí ele falou em descer
agora ele achou ótimo porque ele já era
um empreendedor
ele achava muito legal que eu tivesse
meu próprio negócio
então alguns meses depois eu estava
diante do meu chefe
o fábio e ele estava me olhando com uma
cara meio esquisita ele não estava
acreditando que eu ia sair da empresa
para ser uma fotografia de casamento
ele achava que eu estava escondendo
alguma informação que eu não queria
dizer para onde estava indo
quando ele realmente acreditou que eu ia
tentar uma carreira nova
ele perguntou mas isso dá dinheiro a
reação dos meus amigos também não foi
diferente foi contida mas todos acharam
loucura mas o que eu sabia que aquilo ia
me trazer muita diversão eu sabia também
que se não der certo eu não estava não
tinha problema
então algum tempo depois eu estava em
casa trabalhando com a minha equipe
o meu marido também naquela época
trabalhava em casa eu não tinha o
problema do trânsito que gostava horas
todos os dias para ir pro meu trabalho
eu fazia o que eu amava
fazia muito bons amigos
era uma delícia
é o mais curioso de tudo eu passei a
ganhar mais um casamento que eu fizesse
já me dava mais dinheiro do que eu
ganhava um mês inteiro o meu salário
estava tudo muito bom até maio de 2009
quando a gente fez uma viagem para
buenos aires quando a gente botou o pé
lá a gente percebeu que aquela cidade
tinha tudo a ver com a gente não tem
como a gente não se encantar por buenos
aires e aí meu marido me fez uma
proposta
perguntou o que você acha da gente morar
em buenos aires
e aí eu pensei hum
terei que fazer umas modificações na mil
meus casamentos
eu fazia casamento todo o final de
semana eu poderia concentrar em um ou
dois por mês fazer um bate volta no rio
de janeiro vai morar em buenos aires e o
dinheiro que ganha acima de um pouco os
casamentos aires já era suficiente para
me manter em buenos aires porque em 2009
o câmbio era muito favorável
topei no ano seguinte a gente resolveu
fazer a mudança das coisas mas aí a
gente viu que ia ficar caro demais
em 2010 a gente teve um esforço hercúleo
pra vender tudo a gente tinha coisas que
a gente tinha acumulado naqueles anos
todos naquele apartamento grande que a
gente nem sabia que existia que viviam
ali mas a gente conseguiu
no finalzinho de 2010 a gente vai então
para a argentina
quando a gente coloca os pés lá de novo
a gente percebe que é verão e verão 1 em
buenos aires é tão quente quanto o verão
carioca
meu marido que já não gosta de calor
sugere vamos para o sul da argentina que
o verão é mais ameno ea gente espera o
verão acabar e quando hoje o tônus
iniciar a gente vai para buenos aires se
fixa lá como era o plano original
então nessa neste momento em que a gente
está em bariloche a gente já percebe uma
mudança a gente já se sente muito
aliviado porque a gente não tem nada a
gente já vendeu tudo a
só tem algumas roupas os nossos
notebooks e o meu equipamento
fotográfico todo ea gente percebe que
essa sensação é muito boa de não ter
nada porque tudo que a gente possui
possui a gente
quanto mais coisas a gente tem mais a
gente ancorado ea gente fica sem
capacidade de se movimentar
neste momento o meu marido estava lendo
o livro que falava sobre umas pessoas
diferentes zonas umas pessoas que
viajavam de forma permanente e
trabalhavam pela internet mas elas não
tinham casa fixa nenhum lugar do mundo
mas não é porque elas eram ricas é
porque o dinheiro que elas ganhavam
trabalhando pela internet elas investiam
na viagem ela não tinha uma casa para
manter com contas fixas para pagar
nesse mesmo livro o meu marido e uma
frase de santo agostinho
essa frase dizia o mundo é como um livro
quem não viaja só ler uma página
e aí ele surtou falou eu não quero ler
uma página só eu quero ler o livro todo
eu gosto de viajar e aí faz uma outra
proposta
bhatti que tal se a gente vivia como
essas pessoas diferentes zonas
eu falei um teria que fazer um novo
ajuste nos meus casamentos concentrar
tudo num período do ano passado três a
quatro meses no brasil e os outros oito
meses eu passaria para tanto as fotos e
fazendo os álbuns trabalhando
remotamente de onde estivesse bom legal
é aquela época nós tínhamos também uma
reserva financeira que nos permite
arriscar
voltamos pro brasil e vamos dar a
notícia para os amigos e para a família
final a gente está animado e aí a reação
foi generosa foi pior do que aquela que
ela foi contida essa não
meus amigos principalmente meus amigos
na área de casamento não entenderam
falando assim você tá maluca
você tá querendo jogar tudo que você
conquistou no lixo como assim
se tá bombando como diz lá no rio
tá bem pra caramba como é que você vai
fazer isso e aí nessa hora eu realmente
fiquei bolada
fiquei treme nas bases e eu tive que
fazer uma discussão com meu marido levei
o ponto a reflexão ea gente entender o
seguinte que realmente desapegar dói
demais
não só das coisas materiais que também
dói mas das conquistas nossas
principalmente os profissionais
dói muito jogar fora o que a gente
conquistou
às vezes uma vida inteira e é por isso
que muita gente não faz nada diferente
porque esse medo é muito grande e eu
tava conhecimento também é como a gente
percebeu o seguinte que existe um bem
mais precioso de todos que é o tempo o
tempo não dá para recuperar o segundo
que passa não volta mais
qualquer coisa até à saúde
em certos casos se consegue recuperar o
tempo não ea gente pensou ah a gente é
muito medroso
pra gente é corajoso mesmo é quem faz
todo dia a mesma coisa que deixa amanhã
em investir nos seus sonhos porque o
amanhã pode não acontecer e aí é uma
aposta muito arriscada a gente bom mesmo
é acumular experiências aprendizados
amigos amores isso
além do mais a gente vive no planeta tão
interessante com tanta coisa legal pra
fazer com todas as pessoas legais que a
gente conhecer com tantos cenários
lindos
a gente vai se contentar em ver e uma
cidade com o mundo todo a nossa
disposição
então aí em final em 2010 começa a nossa
jornada numa de lá pra cá foram sete
anos 66 países e mais de 300 cidades e
muitas dessas cidades
a gente ficou algumas semanas a três
meses
a gente teve uma experiência um pouco
mais profunda de como os locais vivem
mas afinal onde a gente mora
bom eu quero deixar claro que a gente
gosta de um conforto
a gente gosta de banho quente e cama
confortável
então a gente aluga que eles
apartamentos que já vem com tudo
incluído já vem com roupa de cama vem
com toalha vem com o fogão vem com
geladeira com tudo incluído a gente paga
um preço cheio por isso a gente tem
muito pouca coisa mas não é porque a
gente não gosta dessas coisas a gente
ama essas coisas mas a gente só não
precisa tê las
a gente pode usar as dos outros e o mais
surpreso em surpreendente de tudo nesses
sete anos
a gente gastou muito menos gastou
viajando do que parado em niterói no rio
de janeiro onde a gente morava quando
alguém chega pra mim fala assim patrícia
eu não tenho dinheiro pra viajar desse
jeito aí eu pergunto você tem de
dinheiro pra se manter no brasil essa
pessoa responder que sim eu falo cara cê
tá bem pra caramba porque você tem
dinheiro para viajar o mundo sim que
brasil vai dar pra caramba né
comparado com outros países a gente
desses sete anos
2 os dois primeiros anos a gente ficou
meio na solidão eu vivi e eu ali né nas
viagens
a gente queria fazer amigos mas a gente
só não sabia como a gente não podia
chegar alguém na rua oi
esse é meu amigo eu sou muito letal mas
só que é difícil isso até que no início
do terceiro ano dessa jornada a gente
descobre o carro de som a fintar de
safin é uma comunidade online muito
interessante onde tem cadastrados
moradores locais do mundo inteiro e
nessa comunidade a eventos e são e foram
nesses eventos que nós fizemos muito
bons amigos e nós mantemos contato com
eles até hoje
e por falar em amigos que eu tenho uma
passagem muito interessante em 2012
nós chegamos em beirute no líbano ea
gente quando chegou lá a gente tava é um
pouco premido por aquele caos da cidade
grande
foi aí que eu tive uma idéia faltam
amigos eu vou entrar no facebook vou
escrever aqui se existe algum brasileiro
por aqui perdido pra gente tomar um café
trocar uma idéia e uma menina me
respondeu dizendo que ia chegar em
beirute no dia seguinte porque ela
queria passar o aniversário dela com o
marido que estava embarcado ou a em
beirute
e aí eu falei assim ótimo vamos nos
conhecer então essa menina já me
conhecia porque eu era a fotografia de
casamento ela casou no ano anterior ea
tentou me contratar mas infelizmente a
data já estava ocupada
mas a gente se conhecer no dia seguinte
então a gente resolver esse problema
agora duas coincidências surreais
aconteceram neste momento
uma é que o nome dela era patrícia e o
sobrenome era figueira ou seja tinha o
mesmo nome e o mesmo sobrenome que o meu
é o mais surpreendente ela faz
aniversário um dia antes do meu então
não preciso nem dizer que nós passamos
nosso aniversário juntas
nós trocamos muitas idéias ficamos
grandes amigas e eu comentei com ela
baterias e sabe qual é o auge da
felicidade de um fotógrafo de casamento
é fotografar um casamento fora do brasil
ela falou eu tenho como resolver isso
porque durante o vôo
eu sentei ao lado de um libanês que
estava indo pro casamento da sobrinha
então ela não descansou enquanto ela não
convenceu a família da noiva toda que eu
deveria fotografar o casamento da menina
mesmo que ela já tivesse um fotógrafo
contratado eu ficaria com as fotos mais
legais aquelas fotos mais emocionantes e
aí tudo certo tempo depois eu estava lá
nas montanhas do líbano um designer
fotografando um dia incrível
fotografando um casamento com rituais
são diferentes com rituais de dança de
música de alegria que era incrível era
muito próxima da alegria brasileira
sobretudo por causa dos amigos
essa é uma das muitas histórias que nós
vivemos em que mostram que ter amigos
faz toda a diferença numa viagem que já
aprendeu disso tudo que existem dois
mundos o mundo dos noticiários do mundo
real um dos noticiários diz que o mundo
é perigoso que as pessoas são mais que
elas que o que elas não são legais que
ela não te ajudam e na verdade o mundo
real chega para contradizer isso tudo
que a humanidade é muito boa
as pessoas são muito legais elas te
ajudam e te acolhe se não se fosse assim
a gente assistir se é pra começo de
conversa a tv a gente não iria é ucrânia
que é um dos países que a gente mais ama
no mundo hoje e é um país pacífico com
pessoas muito queridas
a gente também percebeu que a gente está
no melhor momento para viajar que existe
na história porque se a gente olhar
atrás só no século 20 houve duas grandes
guerras mundiais
era difícil se locomover de um ponto ao
outro hoje a gente tem alguns conflitos
ainda mas eles são pontuais
a maioria do mundo é muito pacífico e
mais ainda nós somos sortudos porque a
gente pode usar a tecnologia em nosso
favor
hoje é muito fácil você conhecer tudo de
um país antes mesmo de pisar lá
agora página
nós temos o melhor passaporte que é o
passaporte brasileiro para quem quer ser
o nome do digital
esse passaporte hábito das portas
ele permite você e assim visto pra tanto
os países que são significativos para
quem quer ser um novo edital
a gente aprende também a viver com pouco
tudo que a gente tem hoje está ali
naquela mochila naquela linha
ali tem a nossas roupas todas roupas
para 10 dias
eu levo também uma botinha um tênis e um
par de chinelos e o meu escritório
também
e todo o equipamento fotográfico e
videográfico cabe naquela naqueles
volumes
a gente fez uma ferramenta para você
fazer uma autoavaliação se vocês tem
tudo pra ser um número digitais é um
questionário que leva dois minutos para
ser respondido super gostoso
vocês vão gostar bom essa vida muito
legal mas a gente tem que fazer muitos
desapego us é muito difícil desapegar da
família dos amigos dos lugares
familiares da nossa língua e da nossa
cultura da nossa comida que pra mim é
melhor do mundo principalmente da minha
terra quebra do pará e também a gente
tem que dizer pegar muitas vezes a nossa
identidade em 2014 no finalzinho decidir
parar de fotografar casamentos para
buscar uma terceira carreira e foi aí
que eu percebi como é difícil você é
deixar essas conquistas para trás e
buscar algo que você ainda nem sabe que
é aquela época não sabia eu estava
completamente perdida e foi aí que eu
enfrentei um ano de 2015 inteiro doentes
com sintomas físicos
eu conheci hospitais e médicos de muitos
lugares lindos que eu poderia
aproveitando eu percebi que os sintomas
eram físicos
eu sentia taquicardia acordar meu marido
madrugada fosse me leva o hospital
porque eu enfartar até meu braço estava
dormente chegar no hospital não tinha
nada né
e aí eu percebi eu a ficha que apesar
dos sintomas serem físicos a causa
emocional eu sofri deixar de ser a
fotógrafa conhecida o rio de janeiro e
passar a ser ninguém porque é difícil
ser ninguém quando já se foi alguém mas
a gente sabe que é preciso abrir mão a
gente conquistar outras coisas porque
como diz o ditado chinês é preciso
esvaziar a xícara para experimentar
novos chassis
obrigada
[Aplausos]